republican senator ben sasse of nebraska
has blamed president trump for the
violent assault on the capitol calling
it
an inevitable and ugly outcome he joins
us now
to discuss good morning to you senator
sasse let's get right to the question
that everybody is thinking and talking
about
should president trump be impeached or
should the 25th amendment be invoked at
this point
it's been quite a week well gail first
thanks for having me on
and my wife and kids and
our prayers go out to the family of
officer shipnick
and the families of the other four uh
who died as well and we've obviously
still got some other folks in critical
condition so let's just start by
recognizing this as a day of mourning
here's what here's what happened on
wednesday um
uh an insurrectionist mob tried to
disrupt the people's house
the the dome of the united states
capital is the most powerful
uh symbol of freedom anywhere in the
world all over the world there's
actually polling that shows when you
hear freedom or liberty
uh the most common image that comes to
anybody's mind anywhere in the world is
the dome of the united states capital
an insurrectionist mob came and marched
on that capital after a rally with the
president of the united states where he
told them to come to the capitol and to
go
wild we all know that that leads to the
question that leads to the question
should the president of the united
states be impeached of the 25th
amendment
and vote so i think we need to draw a
distinction between two really important
things
one is the objective fact about whether
or not the president was involved
in citing this and whether or not the
president of the united states by his
constant addiction to stoking division
was flagrant in his duties to his oath
that's unquestionable
he was flagrantly disregarding his oath
of office
so that that's not in debate the
question is more of a prudential
question
what is the best thing for america in
2022 or 2032. the question isn't what's
best for donald trump
uh at a human level lots of us should
have pity for the man
but at the level of the office i don't
really care what happens to
to donald trump the man in 2023. what i
care about is what happens to the
american people in 2023 what brings
85 and 90 and 95 percent of our people
together
um the one thing that we know is that
the american people rendered a judgment
on donald trump's presidency
and they said go now they want they want
him gone
and in 12 days whatever the right math
is joe biden is going to be the
president
excuse me but i'm really worried about
time because i understand everything
you're saying but here we are we sit
here today there are actually people in
that crowd that think
president trump was leading them to the
capitol i saw interviews with people
saying
we're following the president the
question on the table right now
is what do you think should happen to
president trump should there be
consequences since everybody agrees even
his closest allies
agree that he has incited this what
should happen to him now i
i see you dancing all around and saying
no i'm not i'm not dancing
well just answer okay i don't mean to be
disrespectful you know
you know i'm a fan of you and your work
i don't hear you being disrespectful but
i disagree with you
you said the most important question
right now is what happens to donald
trump that's not right
the most important question is what
happens to the united states people and
this union
12 days and beyond donald trump has
acted
shamefully he has been in flagrant
dereliction of his duty
and he will be remembered for having
incited this and for having drawn
more division into an already divided
people
that is who donald trump is that is what
his legacy is going to be
but i disagree with you that the most
important question is inside the next 12
days the most
important question is what happens to
america after the next 12 days and not
just 12 weeks and 12 months from now but
12 years from now
and so the house if they come together
and have a process
i will definitely consider whatever
articles they might move
because as i've told you i believe the
pr the president has
disregarded his oath of office he swore
an oath
to the american people to preserve
protect and defend the constitution
he acted against that what he did
was wicked that said the question of
what the house does now and how the
senate responds to it over the next 12
days
is a critically important question but
the most important question is the
prudential one
of how we bring the country back
together five and ten and fifteen years
in the future
and there's a lot to be hashed out there
i want to say one thing particularly
about what the house might move their
articles on though
i have been involved in an investigation
that started last night
trying to understand why the national
guard was not deployed
where the people's house was under
assault because i want to understand
what was happening when the mayor of dc
and ultimately
your previous story mentioned the
failures of the the capitol police and
that's obviously true an investigation
has already been launched there
but when the mayor and the chief of
police were calling on the pentagon
to make sure that they were getting the
backup they needed
from the national guard the national
guard wasn't deployed for
hours as the house was being taken over
the the capital the house and the senate
were being taken over by these violent
uh thugs
um the national guard wasn't being
deployed we need to know why that
happened
they were ultimately deployed but where
was the president in that process
because
one of the things we know is when we
were in the senate chamber trying to
certify
joe biden's rightful election we saw the
vice president of the united states
whisked out of our room by the secret
service this is
this is uh kind of third world senator
sas when you think about it you could
have all been killed that day it is very
chilling and very shocking
when my brain goes there i'm just so
relieved that everyone is safe
outside of the five people that were
killed very tragically and now president
trump is condemning them
so really there's more to the story as
you know it'll continue
we thank you for your time this morning
thank you gail thank you